765 let's go next to the caller from the
765 area code
go ahead hi David Thomas Lee and thanks
for taking my call no problem go ahead
Thomas I want um I did some work for
teachers Without Borders several months
back and I visited your native homeland
Argentina and beautiful country I stayed
in Buenos Aires I did some outreach work
laws there and we went into lower and
poverty areas and we got to work with
families and farmers and visually it's
captivating a lot of what you see it's
not something you see typically back
here in the state just in terms of
visual and just in terms of like the
health care that they receive the lack
of none what in your experience or like
I can't what I want to ask is do you
think we can legislate compassion or is
this a human empathy thing that comes
from you know schooling at a young age
from parenting from friendships could
you just elaborate on that a little bit
well listen we know that more education
and more worldliness more interaction
with different people visiting other
places even just learning about other
places in people's all of that stuff
only has a positive effect on our
ability to empathize with others and to
push for policy that might not do
anything for us but we understand how by
virtue of it being better for others
it's objectively good and it will have
positive externalities so there's even
you can even kind of be selfish but
still have empathy so for example you
might not have any concern because
you're a super wealthy person about not
being able to afford health insurance
right like as an example but you could
still recognize you might not even
really care about the people that don't
have health insurance but you can still
recognize how if everybody has health
insurance you have fewer people who need
to for example turn to crime to steal
things they can sell in order to pay for
health care costs right that's still
good for you so you can even be selfish
and still advocate for empathy
policies for reasons other than you just
empathize with other people so I think
that the problem is twofold yes there's
a stunning lack of empathy and people
like I mean I don't know even Gary
Vaynerchuk who if people don't know who
that is look him up who's like a
business guy
he even has started to say that empathy
is like a secret weapon or something
like that he says that is a problem but
even also for a second considering how
there can be difficult to measure
externalities where the more empathetic
policy will also be better for you so
even if you're just a selfish person you
should still be advocating for the
empathetic policy so it's a combination
of education political bias and sort of
lack of world awareness that I think
we're up against I like how you said
that because I'm a lot of the people I
worked with down there it goes under the
the saying there's no true form of all
tourism but like there are some people
that I working with that this the whole
experience was just something to Pat on
your resume you know right I'll send you
you work with you know Habitat for
Humanity there's just stuff to build
themselves up for a further career and I
remember talking just to a lot of the
you know natives there and some of the
people in my group and it is it selfish
if you do something if it is it selfless
if you do something selfishly or is it
selfless and you know it it kind of
twist your mind but no I say it was just
very powerful and you know a lot of that
stuff you know you bring back with you
and you kind of see the world at a
complete 180 now yeah I appreciate you
taking my call thank you appreciate you
calling in and glad you had a good time
in Argentina today's program is made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to bed
help.com / Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you
you can change therapists if you don't
think that it's a good fit it's less
expensive than seeing someone in person
you will still get the professional help
and it is unlimited you can talk to a
therapist every day from home or
wherever you are go to better help calm
/ Pakman it is so easy to sign up and
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube
better help calm /pa que ma n if you've
been wanting to talk to somebody but for
whatever reason haven't please go to
better help calm slash PA que ma N